The
world has an eerie fascination with serial
killers.
Whether it's hearing tales of the men who
process their victims through meat grinders
in order to feed the remains to future victims,
or stories of strange fetishes and incomprehensible
desires to commit atrocities upon corpses,
people can't help but be intrigued.
This dark side of the human psyche has been
featured on screens big and small for decades,
and there is something undeniably captivating
about true crime.
It doesn't let you look away.
Today, we're used to the idea of criminal
profiling.
It's the science of looking at a crime and
its victims in order to understand everything
we can about its perpetrators.
It's easy to forget that modern Criminology
is a relatively new science, pioneered by
one man who joined the Federal Bureau of Investigation
in 1970.
Although he first started out in SWAT and
later became a hostage negotiator, it was
when John E Douglas finally ended up in the
classroom at Quantico that he found his life's
calling.
He spent much of his career investigating
some of the most violent, dangerous criminals
who have ever stalked and preyed upon the
innocent.
Douglas logged years of work interviewing
dangerous men, trying to uncoil just what
made them tick.
You may not recognize his name, but you certainly
recognize the characters that have been based
on him, and the shows inspired by his life.
His story has been the inspiration for Silence
of the Lambs, as well as the show Criminal
Minds.
A fictionalized version of him was portrayed
in Netflix's Mindhunter.
Douglas really did sit down with some of the
most notorious serial killers and violent
offenders the country has ever seen, using
what he learned from them to build the groundwork
for the science of criminal profiling.
Unsurprisingly, spending years in the midst
of psychotic killers is a health hazard.
As you’ll find out in today’s Biographics,
Douglas was fortunate to escape with his life.
TITLE: Into the head of the devil
Douglas wrote the book Mindhunter: Inside
the FBI's Elite Serial Crime Unit about his
experiences in the early days of behavioral
analysis.
The Netflix series of nearly the same name
took liberties with the story, as his life
was shaped into the character of Holden Ford.
While there was a bit of creative license
taken with the details, there was a lot of
truth in the show, too — starting with his
motives for deciding to interview serial killers
in the first place.
Now, it's important to note that the FBI already
had a Behavioral Sciences Unit before Douglas
came on the scene.
It was established in 1971, and law enforcement
already knew how valuable psychology could
be in tracking down criminals.
But here's the thing: it wasn't systemized.
There was no manual, no set of classifications
and definitions, no framework to base assessments
on.
When Douglas transferred there in 1977 to
begin teaching hostage negotiation and applied
criminal psychology, the department was still
new.
And so was Douglas.
On paper, he looked great.
He was going into the classroom with a few
years of military service behind him and seven
years as a field agent under his belt, but
he was still only 32 years old.
And he'd seen how classrooms worked at Quantico.
Instructors needed to be at the top of their
game because sometimes, they were teaching
the details of a case to agents and officers
who had actually worked the case.
And those agents didn't hesitate to challenge
an instructor if they said something even
slightly wrong.
Douglas realized that the fastest way to learn
cases and criminals was to go right to the
source.
He needed to build up some serious credibility,
so he started talking to some of the nation's
most infamous criminals.
Douglas began setting up interviews with the
most prolific serial offenders of his time,
and during that era, there were plenty of
men available to him.
The 1970s, 80s, and 90s would become known
as a golden age of serial killers, with more
than 80 percent of the 20th century’s serials
cropping up during those three decades.
Criminologists now believe the serial phenomenon
had something to do with the coming-of-age
of men who had been raised in the aftermath
of World War II, an event that left broken
families and broken people to raise their
children.
Ted Bundy, Charles Manson, John Wayne Gacy.
Ed Kemper, Richard Speck, David Berkowitz.
The list is a long one, and it keeps going
far past the headliners.
For the public at large, each name was associated
with a terrorized community, or a series of
gruesome crimes; for John Douglas, each name
was another corrupted mind to probe and explore.
Douglas found that what he was learning from
some of the most deviant minds the bureau
had ever crossed paths with could be applied
to all violent crimes, not just murders.
At first, he said he started conducting interviews
"for survival," but it wasn't long before
he realized the work would allow him to provide
some valuable insights into future investigations.
Of course, not everyone agreed with him or
his methods.
His biggest detractor?
The FBI.
TITLE: Douglas vs. the FBI
Douglas’ exploration into the criminal mind
has been undeniably invaluable, but at the
time he was actively conducting interviews,
the powers-that-be at the FBI didn't see it
that way.
At all.
The FBI was concerned, among other things,
about bureaucracy and the chain of command.
Douglas was the one out in the field, traveling
the country, interviewing serial killers and
getting to know the local officers who were
actually on the front lines of all these cases.
When everyday officers needed help on open
investigations, many local offices started
calling him directly, instead of jumping through
the hoops of a more official FBI communication
channel.
Douglas never wanted to turn anyone away for
bureaucratic reasons, because he knew that
red tape was likely to discourage agents he
could quickly advise.
Rather than scold officers or agents for coming
straight to him, he’d help them develop
a profile or advise on what information should
be released to the media.
Sometimes, Douglas felt that conflict very
acutely in some of the most unlikely places.
One of the first big cases that the young
Behavioral Science Unit consulted on was the
case Netflix's Mindhunter presents on center
stage: the Atlanta child murders.
The case was real, and the killing spree began
with the 1979 murders of 13-year-old Alfred
Evans and 14-year-old Edward Hope Smith.
Originally thought to be just another drug-related
killing, it wasn't until somewhere around
19 more children either disappeared or turned
up dead that law enforcement began to connect
them, finally seeing what the community had
been trying to tell them all along: there
was a killer on the loose.
Douglas went to Atlanta in 1981, walking the
woods where bodies had been found and reviewing
files.
He wasn't exactly welcomed with open arms,
though.
After sitting down for an FBI-sanctioned interview
with People magazine — during which he said
he was certain they were looking for a killer
who was black — he suddenly found himself
working with a field office that was less
than thrilled with the effects they believed
his comments were going to have.
The entire situation was a powder keg.
The community had already organized an intitiative
called STOP, which they did hoping to convince
the Atlanta Police Department to view the
killings as connected.
But an undercurrent of racism and accusations
that some of the local cops were card-carrying
members of the Ku Klux Klan overshadowed any
earnest efforts Douglas was trying to make.
At the time, the black community was certain
the KKK was responsible, and the idea that
a white FBI agent sat down and publicly declared
the killer was black just didn't sit well
with many and gave the impression that law
enforcement wasn't entirely on the side of
impartial justice.
Douglas's comments just looked bad.
It was a sentiment that may have been somewhat
assuaged had the FBI agents in the Atlanta
field office been introduced to the media,
especially Special Agent in Charge John Glover,
who was the first black agent to lead a field
office.
There were no introductions, and instead,
Douglas was told repeatedly that he was on
the verge of starting a race war.
Douglas found himself fighting an uphill battle
to get anyone to listen to his ideas, including
applying his profile to the attendees at the
Frank Sinatra and Sammy Davis Jr. benefit
concert, which was organized to help fund
the city's massive manhunt.
He'd hoped to get agents on board with his
case theory on vetting all attendees at the
concert, which would have eliminated women
and suspects without a car before moving on
to racial filters.
Douglas hoped that process would give them
a pool of suspects to investigate further,
but it was never done.
Sadly, it might have helped.
Wayne Williams, the man later arrested in
connection with at least some of the murders,
not only fit the profile, but was at the concert.
Douglas long maintained Williams was the right
collar for some of the cases, but he's also
remained steadfast in his belief that he wasn't
the only killer.
That was based on not just his assessment
of the crimes, but of patterns seen in the
choice of victims.
As for Williams, he was convicted of the murder
of two adults associated with the case, but
the murders of the children have remained
unsolved.
The case was reopened
in August of 2019.
TITLE: The perfect interview
What is
the one thing that anyone fascinated by true
crime and psychology would love to do a deep
dive into?
The transcripts and recordings of Douglas'
interviews with people like Charles Manson
and Ed Kemper, right?
Here's the thing: transcripts and tapes of
most of his interviews don't exist.
Part of Douglas’ work wasn't just in figuring
out the right questions to ask -- it was figuring
out how to get them to answer and how to interpret
those answers.
When he first began conducting his interviews,
he brought along a tape recorder, but it wasn't
long before he realized that the recording
was a huge mistake that was only making his
subjects suspicious of him.
Douglas was already at a disadvantage going
in, as a member of the law enforcement system
that had arrested, tried, convicted, and sentenced
them.
He already represented the authority that
ordered them around every day, and when he
recorded conversations or tried to write them
down, he found that two things happened.
His subjects grew suspicious that what they
were saying was going to be used against them
somehow, and when he wrote, they grew angry
and belligerent.
They wanted his full attention, and they weren't
getting it if he was looking elsewhere.
In order to get them to talk, Douglas knew
he had to create an environment that would
facilitate a dialogue, and that meant he had
to skip a recording device.
He had to rely on memorization.
There are a few things he discovered were
necessary to getting the information he wanted,
and it started before he even set foot in
a prison.
Preparation was essential, and he would spend
time going through every aspect of the cases
associated with the person he was speaking
to.
Police reports, crime scene photos, autopsy
details… it was a grisly amount of information
to sift through, but it would allow him to
know when the offender was being truthful
and when he was lying.
And they lied a lot; if he could call them
out on it, though, that went a long way in
establishing a relationship.
It allowed him to demonstrate how well he
knew their case or how closely he'd studied
them.
To a serial killer, that's flattering.
After the memorization game, most everything
else came down to comfort and control, but
he learned that control is a tricky thing.
There's a scene that happens at least once
an episode in almost every police procedural:
law enforcement goes into a room where a suspect
is being held and confronts them.
There's a lot of anger, some posturing, a
lot of shouting, and usually a lot of accusations.
That is the exact opposite of the atmosphere
Douglas knew he needed to create.
He always stressed that it wasn't an interrogation,
it was a conversation.
Conversations go both ways, and often times,
that meant killers had questions for him.
They asked about his job, his family… and
he answered, truthfully.
By answering the questions asked of him, he
could create the illusion that they were the
ones in control.
They knew something about him, and it made
them giddy.
Over the years, Douglas built up a playbook
for interview techniques.
He outlined how important the setup of the
room was, and stressed that seating arrangements
should be made based on personality.
For example, he gave paranoid individuals
the chance to be seated so they could always
see a door or a window, and dominant personalities
like Charles Manson would be given the chance
to sit above him, looking down.
And they usually took it.
Certain words, like "murder" and "killing"
were never used.
Blame was never projected, and disgust or
judgement was never shown.
He was always careful to keep his body language
and posture relaxed and neutral, and even
likened it to the sort of way one might act
on a first date.
There was never any negativity, but feigning
empathy was sometimes a must.
Sympathy for the devil, indeed.
In the end, it was often one simple thing
that got many of recent history's most notorious
serial killers to open up to him: he played
to their narcissism and their sense of pride
in themselves and in their crimes.
In short?
Given the chance, many killers love to talk
about themselves, especially if they have
a captive audience.
TITLE: The worst of the worst
For many ordinary folk, the idea of coming
face-to-face with a serial killer is terrifying.
But who did someone who interviewed serial
killers on a regular basis rank as the worst
of the worst?
For starters, Lawrence Bittaker.
In 1978, Bittaker met Roy Norris at the California
State Prison.
They shared a morbid fantasy of kidnapping
and killing teenage girls after brutally torturing
them.
And they did, killing five girls between the
ages of 13 and 18.
Douglas thought he was particularly bad because
he looked so ordinary.
Normal.
The sort of guy these teenage hitchhikers
wouldn't have thought twice about getting
in a van with.
Unfortunately for them, he had nicknamed his
van the "Murder Mack".
Bittaker and Norris made auto recordings as
they tortured the girls, and Douglas had the
tapes.
When Scott Glen was getting ready to play
his fictional counterpart in Silence of the
Lambs, he had the actor come to his office.
He played the tapes, and says Glen's response
was emotionally charged.
"John," he said, "I was against the death
penalty, but I didn't know there are people
like that."
The interview that stood out to Douglas as
one of the most fascinating also has a Silence
of the Lambs connection, and it was the killer
who was the inspiration for Buffalo Bill.
Gary Heidnik was convicted in 1989, found
guilty of holding women in what came to be
known as Heidnik's House of Horrors as he
beat, raped, tortured, and killed them, forcing
his surviving captives to help dismember the
dead, then mixing the remains with dog food
and feeding it to his prisoners.
Douglas has also talked about the one truly
unnerving thing that all interviews have in
common: the environment.
He said: "...going into prisons, the doors
clanging behind you.
The noise level in the prisons, it's just
so loud.
I don't trust the inmates.
At times, I don't even trust corrections…"
TITLE: The warning signs
As Douglas collected more information, he
and his colleagues began compiling it into
a centralized database called ViCAP, or the
Violent Criminal Apprehension Program, and
it's worth a quick aside to mention two of
those colleagues.
Douglas wasn't working alone; he had a partner
in FBI agent Robert Ressler.
Ressler joined the FBI in 1970 and transferred
to the BSU when it was formed.
He's the one who coined the term "serial killer".
Douglas also worked with a forensic nurse
named Ann Wolbert Burgess, who started out
working with the victims of sexual abuse and
did some of the first formalized studies of
rape cases in Boston.
The FBI director at the time, William Webster,
saw it as valuable information his agents
needed to be trained in, and later, Burgess
was brought on board to help translate what
Douglas and Ressler were learning into academic
terms that could be applied to other cases.
Together with a small team who Burgess remembers
as not getting much resistance from the powers-that-be,
simply because "it wasn't seen as important
at the time," Douglas began to try to make
sense of what they were learning from the
criminals they were interviewing, and patterns
began to emerge.
The first was the idea that a killer could
be either organized or disorganized, essentially
meaning they either planned their crimes or
did not.
From there, they developed a method of looking
for patterns within the crimes, signatures
specific to certain killers that could be
used to tie murders together, and behaviors
that hinted at motivation.
As he has often said, "If you want to understand
the artist, look at his art."
Douglas determined that at the heart of serial
criminals of almost any kind are three words:
"Manipulation.
Domination.
Control."
Why are these driving factors there?
According to Douglas, his interviews uncovered
a pattern now familiar to anyone who watches
crime shows.
The behavior of predators was formed in childhood,
when, he said, they "all grew up without forming
trusting bonds with other human beings during
their formative years."
He developed ideas regarding the questions
of nature vs. nurture, too.
Are serial killers born or made?
He argued: "...while no one who does not have
certain inborn tendencies toward impulsivity,
anger, and/or sadistic perversion is going
to evolve into a predator because of bad upbringing,
there is no doubt in my mind that those possessing
such inborn tendencies can be pushed along
the path to predation by negative influences
as they grow up and mature."
Many of these ideas are embodied in one of
the most notorious serial killers that Douglas
ever interviewed.
When Douglas talked to Ed Kemper, he was in
jail for killing his mother, her friend, and
six college students.
Kemper gave a full confession and showed police
where to find the bodies, despite the fact
that he was well-known to those police.
Some called him "Big Ed," and he liked to
hang out and drink with them at a local bar.
As Douglas talked to him, he found the roots
of his crimes went back into childhood.
He had a terrible relationship with his abusive
mother, and after being relentlessly bullied
and abused by his grandparents, he killed
them both when he was just 15.
His history of violence went back even further,
to when a 10-year-old Kemper killed the family's
cat.
Kemper embodied something Douglas found in
all serial predators he interviewed, and he
described it as an internal conflict where
feelings of self-importance, grandiosity,
and superiority were constantly at war with
feelings of inadequacy and inferiority.
Add in a childhood full of abuse, and it's
a recipe for a killer.
And much of the time, the signs are there
from childhood.
Douglas described another pattern he saw,
called "the homicidal triad".
It's cruelty to animals, starting fires, and
bed-wetting, a group of behaviors that can
indicate something is deeply wrong.
None of it, he was careful to stress, excused
any of their actions as in the end.
They did what they did of their own free will.
TITLE: Stare long enough into the darkness...
Douglas spent almost his entire career getting
inside the heads of serial offenders who have
acted on some of their deepest, darkest desires,
fantasies so horrible they would have made
the devil blush.
Did they get into his head in return?
Absolutely.
In 1983, he headed to Seattle to consult on
the Green River Murder case.
He said goodbye to his wife at their home,
then, on a hunch, he headed to the school
where she was teaching and said goodbye again.
By the time he hit Seattle he had a raging
headache, and told the other agents he was
working with that he thought he was getting
the flu.
That was Tuesday night, and he told them that
he was taking off until Friday.
The week went by, Friday came along, and no
one had heard from him.
They kicked open his door — Do Not Disturb
sign and all — and found him.
He had collapsed, and spent three days on
the floor in a coma.
The official diagnosis was viral encephalitis,
and post-traumatic stress disorder.
He spent five months in rehab, and was told
that something needed to change.
Did it?
That's debatable.
Douglas oversaw an average of 1,000 cases
each and every year, up until his retirement
in 1995.
Post-retirement, he continued to write about
the cases he studied, give lectures, and work
on high-profile cases like the JonBenet Ramsey
case and the West Memphis Three.
The nightmares were worse when he was young.
Part of that might be because of his belief
that the night is the best time for quiet
introspection, for going over the details
of cases, crime scenes, and interviews, of
dissecting everything for every last bit of
information.
It's hard to turn off what he saw and heard
during the day, and while it's a vital part
of being in law enforcement to become desensitized
to certain sights and sounds, Douglas couldn't
allow himself to do that.
Not when he was trying to learn what made
them do the things they had done.
"What I do…
I felt like I could not put up any kind of
wall,” Douglas said.
“To really understand and interpret a crime,
you have to walk in the shoes of the offender
as well as the victim…"
And that means visualizing everything.